ahmed al Majid can barely move his
fingers it's the morning after another
cold night on the Greek island of Lesbos
Ahmed and his friends ran out of
firewood long ago now they'll use what's
left of this cardboard box to heat
today's first cup of tea Ahmed al Majid
is from Iraq he's been here on the
island of Lesbos for two months now in a
makeshift camp just outside the Moriya
refugee camp we don't have a water for
washing so we have many many many
refugees sick but we don't have a
medicine here
next door is the official camp Moria it
looks like a high-security prison made
for refugees that have come to the Greek
islands in the hopes of continuing on to
north and Europe they have to wait here
until their asylum applications have
been processed authorities strictly
forbid filming here wherever you look
you'll see garbage and feces and people
living right in the midst of it the
refugee camp at Moria is full far beyond
its capacity and with more people
arriving than leaving conditions here
are getting worse every day Ahmed wants
to show us what's happening inside the
camp so we follow him with a hidden
camera
the air is filled with the stench of
smoke garbage and feces the United
Nations High Commissioner for Refugees
or UNHCR recently said that Moria was
dangerous for women and children but
they are the ones who must stay here it
seems like a miracle that epidemics
haven't spread within the camp yet many
refugees have taken matters into their
own hands to stay warm
now that it's getting colder they simply
lied old olive trees these trees belong
to local residents daily oohs Kathy Otis
when Stelios visits his fields he has to
struggle to maintain his composure
laughter I mean all these trees are
burnt there's nothing left
these trees won't grow again they're
finished there are 120 trees and now
there's only four nobody cares
the authorities won't stop this or
compensate us every night these people
cut down the trees and burn them the
village of Moria is in a state of
emergency
stelios kathy otis and other villagers
meet here regularly to discuss ways to
deal with the situation the local mayor
Niko's truck alleys has just returned
from talks with the Greek government in
Athens the news isn't good if the
situation goes on like this it won't
take long before we have physical
confrontation up to now we are
tolerating the looting of people's
assets and it's fortunate that things
haven't become violent yet but it's a
matter of time before that happens
ahmed al Majid left his country to
escape violence he doesn't want to be
lumped together with lawbreakers he
wants to leave lesbos but for now a
ferry ticket to Athens remains just a
distant dream
you